Let's do an example of how a
housing bubble can lead to
wealth destruction.
And I really just want to hit
the point home that once
wealth is destroyed, all
legislation can do is
redistribute who takes
the losses.
That you can't create wealth,
all of a sudden, out of
legislation.
You can maybe create incentives
for investment et
cetera, et cetera, but
we'll talk about
that in a future video.
So let's say, in year one, I
have a neighborhood and Toll
Brothers goes out and builds a
new development and they build
five houses.
Let me draw those five houses.
House one, house two,
house three, house
four, and house five.
And let's say, that this was
a normal home buying
environment.
This could have been 1995.
Let's just say, for the sake
of argument, this is 1995.
Although, I want this to be an
abstract example, so we could
call that year one.
But in 1995, these people
find five new families
that go buy the house.
They pay $100,000 each,
for the houses.
These were conforming loans,
there wasn't this whole CDO
and mortgage-backed
security market.
So essentially, these people
have to put 20% down, and they
had good credit scores, and all
the rest. So immediately,
they have $20,000 equity
and an $80,000 loan.
It's my code, E for equity.
Now, we have this whole
securitization, lending
becomes a lot easier, becomes
easier and easier every year
because housing prices go up,
so people stop taking risk
into consideration.
And let's say, we get
to the year 2005.
This could be an abstract
example, it could be year two.
In 2005, all of a sudden
everyone is
getting access to funding.
The people who have houses
actually don't want to sell
the houses because they're
convinced that their housing
prices are going up so fast,
that it's only a matter of
time before they're millionaires
just with the
housing wealth, and then they
could maybe retire off of it.
But there's so much funding
and anyone can get a loan.
And let's say, that these first
homeowners, maybe they
have to move, or maybe they just
want to move to a cheaper
location, or maybe their kids
have gone to college, so they
just want to downsize.
They decide to sell
their house.
And because there's so much
demand out there, anyone can
get a loan, frankly, the person
who's going to be able
to give the highest bid on the
house, is a person, to some
degree, who's most reckless
or most prudent.
And anyway, I won't
go into that.
But let's say, they pay $1
million for the house.
They have no money down, $1
million loan, subprime,
negative amortization, they
had no credit rating, et
cetera, et cetera.
They pay $1 million.
Now, that was the purchase
price of the house.
And we could just say, that
they have zero equity.
And of course, this
guy's great now.
He probably did build equity
over that ten years from 1995
to 2005, but even if he didn't,
even if all he did was
pay the interest on
this $80,000 loan.
This guy, he had $20,000, now
he gets $1,000,000, pays off
the $80,000, so he essentially,
gets $920,000
plus the $20,000 had before.
So he moves to Costa Rica
with $940,000 and
lives like a king.
Although, I've heard Costa Rica
has also become expensive.
But anyway, what happens now
in the neighborhood?
These people didn't
sell their houses.
They didn't find some subprime
individual that was willing to
bid up the house.
Nothing happened, no money
changes hands, but all of a
sudden, these people say, well
you know what, our houses are
just as nice as this first
house that sold.
Maybe it's even better.
So our houses are also
worth $1 million.
So we all have this kind of you
could say, paper wealth
here of $1 million.
Just from one transaction.
And actually, this is a five
house neighborhood, this could
happen in a 500 house
neighborhood.
You just to find one person to
overpay for a house and then
everyone in the neighborhood,
all of a sudden, feels at
their house is worth
that much.
And just out of thin air, just
by one person getting cheap
credit and overpaying for
something, everyone in the
neighborhood thinks that they
just got $900,000 of wealth,
or at least in this example.
You never see a nine-fold
increase in property prices
but it wasn't crazy to see a
two-fold increase in a year.
Well, we have seen nine-fold
increases over ten years, it's
the example here, it's actually
not that crazy.
Anyway, that's all of their
notional wealth.
But all these people
don't want to sell.
One, they like their house,
their kids are still there.
And they say, wow, in ten
years my house went from
$100,000 to $1 million and in
another ten years, my house is
going to go from $1 million
to $10 million.
Why would I sell it; I can then
retire off the house.
They don't think, who could
buy a $10 million
house in ten years.
The only people who could-- well
anyway, I'll do another
video on that, I just don't
want to run out of time.
But they can still
monetize this.
They could say, well when I go
to my financial planner, they
said, oh, it's so inefficient
for you to have all of that
equity sitting in your house.
How much equity do they have?
They had $20,000 before and even
if they didn't build any
equity while they paid their
mortgage, they now have
another $900,000 of equity.
So these people, their financial
planner, and their
siblings, and their friends at
work say, oh, your balance
sheet is so inefficient, why
don't you take some of that
equity and invest it
or put it to work.
So they say, that's
a good idea.
I'll go get a home
equity loan.
So let's say, this person
goes to a bank.
A bank says, OK, sure, I'll
give you a $500,000 home
equity loan, and in exchange,
get 8% interest on that loan.
So this is the bank.
And the bank thinks it
got a great deal.
Because this $500,000 loan
is not an unsecured loan.
It's not as if this person
can't pay, they just file
bankruptcy and there's
nothing that the bank
can get ahold of.
This home equity loan is
secured by the house.
So the bank says, well if this
person doesn't pay that
$500,000 loan, if they default,
for whatever reason,
I get their house.
And their house is
worth $1 million.
And why do I think
it's $1 million?
Because a house in the
neighborhood sold for $1
million and frankly, that's how,
unfortunately, housing
was assessed.
People would just say, oh,
another house in this
neighborhood sold for $1
million, this one must be
worth $1 million because it's a
very similar or maybe even a
better house.
So this banker thinks they
have a great deal.
This is better than
buying treasuries.
I'm getting 8%, maybe
treasuries are
giving me 3% or 4%.
And if they default on it, I
actually get an asset that's
probably worth more than the
loan amount, and I can auction
that off and easily get
my $500,000 back.
So the risk managers within
the bank think they have a
great deal.
And they probably sliced and
diced these things and sold it
to other people and
got it rated as
triple-A and all of that.
But what happens next?
Well let's say, 2005, in our
imaginary universe was the
peak of the credit cycle.
That was the year that credit
was the loosest. And as soon
as some of these people who had
no jobs and got these $1
million loans, they probably
couldn't even pay the mortgage
on their loan, not to speak of
continuing it, or even pay the
low rate on the original
teaser loan.
So maybe, they start to default,
credit starts getting
tighter, and let's say, this guy
actually gets foreclosed.
And so he gives the house
back to the bank.
The bank auctions it off and
let's say, when the bank
auctions it off, it only gets
$300,000 for the house.
And in the meantime, what did
all of these people do with
the $500,000 that they had?
Well their intention was to take
these home equity loans
and put that money to work,
invest it in some way.
And they say, well what's a
better investment than doing
home improvements?
Because we all know a house
is the best investment.
So unfortunately, a lot of
that $500,000 it gets
quote-unquote invested in
granite countertops, two more
bathrooms per house, hardwood
floors, and you can imagine.
They wanted to treat themselves
too, so they did a
little vacation.
So it was invested quote-unquote
in their house.
Because they said, oh well, this
will increase the value
of my house.
And oh, as a side benefit,
I will really look good,
relative to the neighbors
and live it up.
I can live beyond, essentially,
what my income
would predict.
And I've done some videos on
investment versus consumption,
but I'd argue that
this wasn't real
investment, that $500,000.
That this was consumption
because it's not making the
world more productive in any
way; it's not increasing the
total economic pie for the
world, so it's not investment.
It may be an investment if it
somehow makes your asset more
emotionally appealing to
some greater fool to
pay more for it.
You didn't build a factory or
you didn't invent some new
technology that will make all of
us richer, you just poured
some money into something that's
going to make your
lifestyle a little bit better,
and maybe the next person who
buys your house.
But anyway, this house
got foreclosed upon.
It gets auctioned off
for $300,000, maybe
this is the year 2006.
Now, all of a sudden, all of
these people, probably all of
whom who took these home equity
loans, let's say all of
them did it.
They all say, gee, I'm paying
a $500,000 loan.
Actually, I'm paying $500,000
plus my original $80,000 loan,
so, I have $580,000 of
debt on an asset that
just sold for $300,000.
So what do you think they're
going to do?
And I just realized I'm out of
time, so I will continue this
in the next video.